quiet days and silent nights
this is a festive season like no other
here in germany
where traditionally at this time of the
year the streets are bustling with
christmas markets
this year not so after more than 20 000
cases were confirmed on sunday
the chancellor angela merkel announced
most stores would be closing over the
christmas
shopping period as well as further
measures placing
germany into a complete lockdown over
its record number of infections
we urgently need to act the decisions
made today
are the result of that the goal remains
we need a rate of 50 cases per 100
000 people per week or lower this will
all have an impact on the holidays
we know this but we're forced to take
action and that's what we're doing
in italy another grim milestone has been
passed
at least 64 000 people have now died
from covert 19
overtaking the uk for most deaths
resulting from the virus in europe
transmissions had slowed down over the
summer but as the days grew colder
the numbers began to rise again
much hope is being pinned onto a new
vaccination campaign
that will see pavilions set up in
squares across the country
to dispense vaccines the hope that italy
will bloom again
in the coming year france's stay-at-home
policy has now been lifted but a
nighttime curfew is still in place
the government will only loosen the
restrictions when infections fall to
around
five thousand per day but it is a long
way off from that figure
with eleven and a half thousand new
infections announced in the past 24
hours
in the uk during another nail biting
moment in the brexit negotiations
the vaccine rollout has already begun as
the spread of the virus continues
relentlessly
from sixteen and a half thousand new
cases a day on wednesday
to nearly eighteen and a half thousand
on sunday
with the capital once again one of the
worst hit areas
sony gallego al jazeera